the ASVs standard hello everyone my name
is jim manikan I'm gonna be your
presenter for today I want to talk to
you about a really important standard
for web developers and for API
developers to both guide you down the
path of writing secure software but also
guiding your entire organization down
the path of writing secure software my
name is jim manikan
I'm one of the former board members of
the Olas foundation wasp is the open web
application security project an
international charity dedicated to
providing free documents and free
projects all around helping you write
secure code particularly on the web for
the book on the topic of resident of
Hawaii and Virginia so I'm gonna cite a
new term it's called fashion mashup you
heard this term before Robin so okay
what do I have okay so I'm from Hawaii
got the Hawaiian shirt right but I'm
also from Virginia where I live now so I
got like the cowboy these are a writing
formal pull of riding boots I'm English
I'm an English equestrian myself in my
spare time I'm serious and I got a
Scottish wool hat so that's my this is
my excuse for my horrible mashup dress
today by the way if you want to contact
me you could reach me at Jem single
quote a single quote once it would not
equal same quote at mana cocom okay
let's move on so I want to start with
one of the earlier pseudo sorry suede Oh
pseudo standards in the world of web and
API security the OWASP top 10 who's
heard of this document before the OWASP
top 10 anybody liked base your entire
security program on this list III want
to reach and I want to caution you on
this here's why the OWASP top 10 is an
awareness list it is meant to breed
awareness on how to approach application
security but this list is highly flawed
highly flawed these are ten semi random
issues for example look at broken
authentication and session management
this is the world of digital identity
when you're building a login
session management delegation and
Federation system these are all the
pieces of an identity system how complex
is that kind of construction and code
you could build a login system from
scratch this is like a hundred
requirements by itself and what if you
want to stop sequel injection a one
that's parameterizing your queries it's
like a one that's one single technical
issue and where something like X X e
this is an XML level attack this is more
of a legacy issue against XML web
services and it's a singular very
specific attack type or something like
like using known vulnerable components
requires more tooling than secure coding
this is these are really good ideas
these are is a really acceptable list I
think to do things like if a talk at a
conference or to or to read the first
time you're reading about web security
but and friend these are three three
items are relatively new for this
version of the u.s. top ten but this
list is incredibly in complete and the
and the severity and the priority of
these items are highly suspect this is
our opinion on this and again there are
so many major issues missing from this
list you should not base your program
off this at all and and we've been
pushed to base programs off of this if
you're doing e-commerce what what
private set of regulations guides your
work if you're doing e-commerce and
accepting credit cards as part of your
website or API
what regulation is going to be governing
your work this PCI DSS this is the
payment card industry data security
standard and that that's that kind of
standard mandates that you follow the
Olas top ten and this is shite it really
is it pushes people in the wrong
direction to really build a
comprehensive program around building
secure software so again I want to
recommend you go pick up the Olas top
ten read it carefully
two or three
times one of the were the smartest
people in the world bereaved on spots
from Parade magazine from Mensa one of
the smartest women to ever ever walk the
planet she and she added she was asked
how come you're so smart it's like very
outside melts discipline it's not like
I'm naturally smart I'm disciplined I
always read something once for
everything I read from a news article to
a standard to an awareness list I read
it once quickly I read a second time
carefully I read a third time with a
marker so I have a side of my mind and a
physical part of my body connecting by
the time I read it the third time it is
in my brain and this is a really great I
have to read standards for a living
anybody ever read something like the
OAuth standard or other large white
papers how did that make you feel sir
reading that how did you emotionally
feel from that reading processor very
upset I did - oh off - is a am I allowed
to it's not proper to swear in London is
that correct he's like whatever Oh auth
- ISM is a dumpster fire like I've never
seen before from a security point of
view I don't want to be rude to the
standard body but they're not active
developers and they don't know web
security they're the best identity
thinkers on the planet and it alot of
really great work but oauth2 is at best
a dumpster fire it's not something I
think we should be using in a secure
content a secure context Oh auth 2.1
will be much better coming out
relatively soon forcing you to use pixie
and other sub standards around Olaf -
what was the point I was trying to make
a point here was a point I'm trying to
make about this I don't know I'm sorry I
forgot to vote on trying to make is we
really want something more comprehensive
and this list is not going to do the
trick I want to introduce to you the
ASVs standard again this is the
application security verification
standard from the O Austin foundation
this is designed to be not just an
awareness list but an actual
comprehensive standard for developers
for designers for security teams so
everyone has the same definition of what
surety is when I ask you what is secure
software what's the answer to that
question when I ask this question what
is secure software to you here are the
questions I typically get oh that means
my application won't get hacked or my
application surely behaved as designed
these are philosophical answers that do
nothing to help me as a developer write
secure code so I'm an engineer I'm not a
philosopher to be honest with you I do
have a philosophy degree it's a
different story
different story Robin but I'm a
scientist I'm a guy I like to think I'm
a scientist to some degree and I want a
clear standard to define what security
is and that's why we wrote this standard
and essentially ASVs
is the w ASVs the web application our
API application security verification
standard there's been several offshoots
off of the standard that massive the
mobile application security verification
standard the Internet of Things
application verification standard for
the major types of architectures of the
day but this should help you down the
road as a as a web developer or web
service developer really understand the
totality of what your responsibility is
when you care about security
who cares about security by the way who
completely does not care about security
at all no one's raising their hand for
talent how many of you actually get
permission to do security in your work
how many of you are restricted from
fixing security but you're they won't
let you fix security bugs
really have you asked or try to so your
management actively discourages you from
doing security
get out of there dude just quit if they
say why is because your security is
shite and get out of there so seriously
I really recommend if you're working for
a company if you have this luxury and
you want to do security and they're
literally pushing stopping you from
doing it it's harming your career it's
harming your your wellness as an
engineer and you're a but your company
has obviously got their bleep up their
bleep
their push stopping you from doing
secure coding I highly recommend you
move on and that's a audacious thing to
say I know but we're entering an era
we're understanding how to write secure
code and having the experience of doing
it it's fundamental to the wellness of
society this is not just about you and
your career it's also about the
well-being of the world because if we
look at the damage done by cyber
security incidents and attacks on
software around the world this is more
damaging to society than the globe than
the legal global drug trade the damage
that does to society this has come with
the number-one like major problem across
the world to maintain those societies we
have today everything we do is run on
software so I really want to encourage
you to make sure you're at a place where
you as an engineer are allowed to do
security you can continue to learn it's
not like you take a course and you now
know security this is like an
intellectual evolution need to go
through over the course of like ten
years this is really hard it's
challenging everything that we do by
default is relatively insecure it takes
us as a community of developers to care
about this stuff when we built the stand
and it was built by several of us from
different parts of the industry it was
originally built by Jeff Williams Dave
Ricker's
and Mike Barsky these are some of the
earlier adopters of application security
over a decade ago as a standard was
migrated to a new team the team is now
run by Josh Grossman real famous app set
professional did a lot of heavy work on
this last version
Andrew Vander stock but doing
application security for 20 years from
Australia myself I've been writing code
for about 30 years now and and Daniel
Cuthbert who liked it was a professional
hacker who works for like militaries
around the world I mean he's a really
good really high-end
Red Team attacker going after some of
the most important organization in the
world as part of a legal ethical
penetration testing engagements so we're
all from different parts of the industry
we're all good friends as well we know
each other well for many years and none
of us are like none of us are trying to
push an agenda other than helping you
write secure code
in my opinion previous folks who run
this standard they really starts to push
like their personal business commercial
to Ghent into the standard and we
politely kicked them out and brought in
a new team with more objective people so
I'm a real big fan of this current
version of the standard that we're gonna
go through and so here's a little
snippet of the standard right the
standard is essentially a list of
requirements that are one two three
sentences long and that's it there's no
other detail on any of these standards
any of these requirement items and if
you want to look at the details of these
requirement items you can look at
another Olas project called the Oh wash
cheat sheet series which will explain
these in more detail but the goal of
this project is to give you a standard
that you can fork within your own
company so you have your own secure
coding standard to drive how you test
how you build how you design and how you
monitor software from a security point
of view the standard is built in three
different levels of severity each
requirement either level 1 level 1 and 2
or level 1 2 and 3 level 1 is a
requirement that every app on the planet
should follow on the web level 2 is for
like serious financial data serious
financial applications applications with
serious gdpr type of data and similar
that's level 2 level 3 so those are you
building government services or
infrastructure services or software
that's storing the records of billions
of users at this point we really should
be considering level 3 standards and
again III think that even though this is
a standard which implies you should do
what the standard says our real secret
agenda here because this is a hard list
to build it's gonna be different for
everyone
our real agenda here I think a good
agenda in this case is to get you to
grab the standard review it for get with
your team to generate your own standard
that's well vetted by developers when
people roll out a standard like this in
their organization you're going to be
tempted to let security people make the
final decision
and I want to caution against this the
thing that I'm trying to achieve with
this standard is ownership by
development staff so when I roll this
out to my different teams that I consult
for I make sure that as we go through
this list and we choose which
requirements are good and which ones are
not that we let developers lead
developers make the final say what's the
point of this why am I on the security
Pro and ones I've been doing this for a
long time why am I not making the final
call and letting developers make the
final call
again I want to achieve ownership when I
go to a developer here's a standard you
must use this they don't want it nobody
wants to hear that they really a lot of
companies try to do this the ASV s4 is
our new standard and you must use it
you're welcome developers that doesn't
really work so well but if you sit with
developers walk through the requirements
and ask them hey Robin which requirement
do you want to follow this requirement
Robin do you want to allow emoji in
passwords Robin loves a mode he's like
yes I support that requirement and now
because the developer said it's okay now
I'd let that requirement be part of our
work and now developers own it and like
any good legislation once I get it in
and developers agree to it a security
guy I'll sneak my other agenda in later
on yeah and it sounds terrible but this
really works in the real world
ownership helps forcing this on people
doesn't work in my experience and so
again here's the team that built this
myself
Daniel Andrew and Josh Grossman just
been fantastic he really drove the most
recent version of the standard with
Andrew and we have we do this work in
public in github previous versions of
the standard were built in a darkroom in
someone's basement and then they pushed
it out to us without the chance to edit
and we found that to be not the best way
to build a public standard so we did
this version of the standard for the
first time in github and encouraged
everyone in the world to provide
comments and so this is not just our
work it's the work of literally hundreds
of people who are experts in this area
or have experience in this area
or just have wisdom in this area who
provided comments and we addressed every
single comment that came in in detail
this is our job and we did it it's a
long process and this is a result of our
work and so we also made some
modifications to make it a little bit
better for the community we shifted
everything to to markdown so we can pop
which so we can push out many different
versions of it and different different
styles very easily we have all these
scripts to generate the standard
automatically now as we make
modifications you get we push scripts
that generates a whole new version we
see clearly who's making what changes
and we brought the standard in
compliance with admittedly a US standard
NIST 863 but I think this it's not just
because the u.s. standard because
several the members of this team are not
American right the several several team
members are Daniel's from South Africa
Andrews from Australia
Josh's from Israel I'm from the US so
why would three non-us citizens support
a u.s. standard because NIST 863 this is
the digital media authentication
guideline of the US government and it's
it's written primarily by a professional
Jim Fenton and we look at these
standards as a community I'm not always
a fan of it but the consensus of all the
other instructors and application
security people that I know of they feel
that this is a brilliant progressive
standard that's really changing the game
of how we should do authentication
they're really pushing us away from
password based security it's they're
pushing us away from SMS which has a lot
of known problems they're really pushing
us towards Fido and using hardware
tokens for authentication if you look at
today like any form of authentication or
multi-factor that uses a number is
vulnerable to fishing so if like your
bank is SMSing you a text code to blog
in this is pretty weak security for a
bank we want to use hardware tokens push
notification smart cards which is really
the only good kind of authentication we
have in the
today for high-risk applications and
NIST astre is really pushing that
progressive idea head like you're doing
in Europe as well so I think this this
use of 863 requirements that migration
is a really big benefit to the standard
and again multiple European security
professionals have endorsed this work as
well it's not because his American
standards we don't care about American
standards we care about good information
that helps us build good authentication
and identity layers right we also have
this little strange controversy when
building the standard right we the
original version of the standard had web
mobile even native code requirements and
as the standard began to as a standard
progressed in the different versions we
became more and more specific to web
near the end of the 4.0 run I was asked
by other team members to go build an IOT
section so I went out and got Daniel
Miller and Andrew us and a few other
really big IOT experts global experts
and they wrote in a standard such like a
small standard section for us in IOT a
great addition to this and then near the
end of the standard they're like yeah
thanks for doing that Jim we're gonna
get rid of the IOT part and just do web
this year I was a little flustered like
why do we go out and seek the help of
others to only get rid of it so our
negotiation was we took all the IOT work
and put it in the appendix so we're so
their work is still there but it's not
really a core part of the standard the
whole world of IOT Internet of Things
they're gonna push their own standard
out sometime in 2020 so this is a great
idea
breaking the standard up specific to
these major architectures in the world
today love it and so the big change we
made is we change the standard to
address the major changes in how web
applications are being built these days
we we have full support for the whole
serverless micro service kind of
architectures that are becoming the the
framework to shore of the day in
development the idea of building
traditional web
applications is starting to fade the
newest are the most common architecture
I see teams building is using javascript
clients like four different frameworks
right we got Angela
we have react yeah we have view and then
there's smelt which is up-and-coming as
well so a lot of the most development I
see is in one of these four JavaScript
user interface frameworks using Ajax to
talk to an API
sound familiar everyone this and and
this is a really new way of developing a
web app compared to my generation of
traditional web apps using using dotnet
and Java and similar we also edit
requirements for containers because the
whole world is rapidly moving to api's
and web services we have a lot more web
service requirements that we've
considered we're all we also look at a
Dom Dom cross-site scripting JavaScript
programming problems with script
injection we put a lot those
requirements back in then we talk about
templating languages that stop some of
these JavaScript injection attacks on
automatically and again I'm talking
about cross-site scripting this
frustrates me so much we've known about
cross-site scripting for almost 20 years
now
everybody Noah cross site scripting is
by the way this is when the attacker
injects JavaScript into your application
do a comment or a profile that another
user looks at so if I edit my profile
add JavaScript to it then someone else
looks at my profile and execute to that
JavaScript I just got a victim to
execute JavaScript from be the attacker
and that I can deface the site steal
your keystrokes steal any data force you
to take any action it's game over if I
can add JavaScript to your application
in today's in today's world and then
we've gone through so many rounds of how
to fix it like let's do scaping well
that doesn't work now we got to do HTML
sanitization no that's not they get
bypassed so you have to use javascript
correctly so now that all that is too
complicated so let's use content
security policy now oh wait content
security policy one two and three are
all by passable unless you have a
perfect policy so let's build this new
standard called trusted types it's like
I could think of four stand there
in the last 10 years that keep getting
added onto each other to try to stop
cross-site scripting
so we've because it's so complex we've
addressed it in more detail in the
standard we've also mapped all these
requirements to cwe's from the mitre
corporation the common weakness
enumeration mapping this is a public
list of weaknesses or one of the one of
the security definition organizations in
the world when you have a vulnerability
you usually want to when you there's a
vulnerability in common software you'll
get given a CVE code common
vulnerability enumeration code that
refers to that vulnerability type from
the mitre corporation they also have a
list of cwe's these are common
weaknesses in the worlds of software so
we've mapped every requirement but we've
mapped as many requirements as we could
to a cwe in some way and we basically
changed the whole standard think about
standards worth we pushed out standard
number one version one and all those
requirements were numbered and then as
we went to version two we removed
certain requirements and added new ones
and to preserve the numbering like
version 1 was requirement 1 2 3 4 then
requirement 3 went away then we had 1 2
4 and 5 to maintain the same numbering
system once we hit version 3 it was like
there's a requirement 1 7 18 it just the
numbering system got a little little
messy so at at version 4 we wiped the
slate clean and renumber the entire
standard it's a real whole new level of
standard we've reordered every section
we removed a lot of duplicates and we
triaged literally thousands of comments
from the community some of the comments
dated back several years than waiting
for us to actually get to work and we
addressed every single one that came
through our work so again remember this
standard is in three different levels of
severity right level 1 for every app
level 2 for high-risk apps level 3 for
infrastructure kind of apps level 1 is
is something all apps should do and we
believe every
single requirement in level one is
completely testable by scanning tool or
a penetration tester and it's the only
level that's completely penetration
testing and by the way please stop
penetration testing as your only
security task I know if I go back ten
years at the dawn of the application
security era a lot of companies would
basically do this
hey developers just go write code and
get stuff done and near the end of the
project we'll hire a penetration tester
to try to hack the application from an
ethical point of view and we'll go fix
those bugs and then push it push the
software alive how does that process
sound this sounds familiar to anyone
just go ahead and write code guy write
code don't anyone slow you down and
we'll do a little bit of testing a
couple days before we go live fix those
bugs and we're good to go
does this work by the way no it does not
work you know we're in an era and I
still think you should do penetration
testing but it's not the only thing that
you should do we're in the world we're
in the era of software development where
devops should rule supreme in terms of
how you write code what do I mean by
DevOps I hear a lot of people define
this term and give a different meaning I
have my own definition for it what do
you think that the term DevOps means
anybody want to play you know what
that's my definition of it a lot of the
DevOps
principles like gene came and similar if
I say what DevOps is just CD CI CD
continuous integration continuous
deployment I minimize all DevOps down to
that a lot of the real like thought
leaders are this they frown their nose
at that definition because they're like
oh no DevOps is a cultural change and I
don't agree with that I think all the
DevOps is we automate everything we can
around the process of building software
we automate building we automate pushing
live we automate QA and testing and we
should be automating from a security
point of view
the automating security testing in this
era every how often should you be
testing your code for security and the
only good answer and what does agile
mean in the modern era in my opinion you
should be testing your code for security
thousand times a day using automation as
part of a tool like Jenkins whereas I'm
building my every time I build every
time I push every time I touch code a
battery of automated tests get run
static analysis looking at my code for
vulnerabilities dynamic analysis running
a scanner against my running dev version
of my app looking for vulnerabilities
third-party library scanning making sure
that all the libraries I'm using don't
have known security issues against them
those are the three classes of tools
minimum you should be using thousand
times a day while you're writing code in
an automated fashion and so and I see a
lot of teams moving in that direction if
your process is we write code for a
couple months and then do this and then
do some testing I think you're selling
yourself short it's a really it's
expensive to achieve security that way
you want to feel the pain a little bit
at a time as you're working and when a
bug shows up in your work you want to
learn about it right away
fix it right away as opposed to letting
it go live and then fixing it let me ask
you one more question before we get too
much further what do I mean by the
concept agile anyone has anyone here an
edge an agile developer edge who here is
an agile developer okay can I pick on
you for a second who's agile again agile
come on how often do you push code how
often are you capable as a team of
pushing code live in if you had to move
fast how often if you wanted to could
you push code live
okay I'm not sure I'm gonna give you a
hard time it's not I'm not trying to
attack you personally I guess I kind of
am I'm gonna attack you outside this
fair bear with me when you're when
you're pushing code three times a year
and that's your capability guess what
you're not at all
you're not agile see agile is both a
discipline and just benefits from that
discipline what are the what's the
discipline part of agile back in my era
we use experiment we have multiple
people we'd shift the team around so
everyone knew every part of the
architecture we were we had a really
robust architecture that we can roll out
production quality on a very frequent
basis this is the spiral model of
development what else is agile low
documentation but strong architecture
upfront and a few other similar
principles the point is it's a
discipline you know what most big
companies do they want to be they like
they loved it they loved the concept of
agile because once you've done the
discipline of agile the benefit is I
should be able to add requirement to the
app at any time I should be able to add
new requirements to the process anytime
I need to as management there what a lot
of big companies do is they do that to
you as a developer they give you
drive-by requirements all throughout the
process but they don't want the
discipline parts of agile and guess what
when you're getting all kinds of new
drive-by requirements while you're
trying to freakin get your work done and
all the discipline stuff you're told not
to do that guess what you're not even
close to you're no longer agile you're
agile in name only and now you're only
pushing code a couple times a year
that's Bork dude it's not your about
blaming you it's just it's a process
it's a it's a situation that many big
companies are in do you know how often
you should be able to push code if
you're really an agile shop in 2020
what's that how about a thousand times a
day seriously new people who go work for
Etsy you know what their first job is to
push their profile live immediately
because they have a massive DevOps
automation and
structure that takes every check-in
every push live and runs it through
thousands of security tests before they
allow that to happen so it's a natural
part of how developers write code so all
this this infrastructure of security
testing and automation is wrapped around
our every now your agile and this is not
I'm not you know I'm not attacking you
personally this is a problem in many big
organizations today they say they're
agile but they can only push live a
couple times a year and that's that's a
problem so again you want to be agile
should be using jenkins or some other
kind of automation with high quality
architecture duplication of duties
across your teams so you could rock and
roll and move fast and be able to push
code live at a regular basis all
throughout the day one more note on real
agile is you can't you really got to
have a lot of pieces in place like I
want it when I build a software are
committing
is get my architects together and build
the authentication layer the access
control layer any kind of cryptographic
key storage a crypto system I need my
base configuration and any other major I
understand my components to build a
secure user interface and all the
libraries I need for security I in
services I need for security
I get those in place first and then
start writing the application and those
pieces may evolve over time but a lot of
folks will jump into a project start
from scratch and try to figure out how
to do security along the way and that's
that's an expensive often fragile
process anyways agile I'm sorry that's
my little agile rant we also got in sync
we also made sure ASVs was in sync with
the payment card industry data security
standard the recent version 6.5 and so
now we're we brought things like buffer
overflows and numeric operations back
into the fold of the standard just to
appease PCI I don't even think about
buffer overflows anymore in my work I
work primarily in Java and c-sharp where
buffer overflows are
kind of managed by the language but
there's a lot of card systems even
web-based card systems still depending
on C and lower-level languages so PCI
did ask us to put those standards back
into ASVs which we did
whenever I fork it from my own teams I
immediately remove this stuff I don't
think buffer overflow is something that
modern most modern web developers need
to care about as other buffer overflows
in c-sharp by the way do you have oh I
don't think there is right just a man
upper level it's like a virtual language
so what's that but you're back to a
buffer overflow type stuff and it's -
it's a shame let's just move on all
right what we removed from ASVs is even
more telling we got rid of we went
through all these every single
requirement one at a time and asked a
question do we really need this and
removed a lot of interesting but not as
impactful controls out just that just
kind of confuse the issue we also got
rid of any controls that are specific to
any one programming language or
implemented by only one specific browser
right and we got rid of the mobile
chapter because that may move to a whole
new standard the massive mobile
application security verification
standard and we included the IOT chapter
and they're gonna build their own
standard next years or later this year
as well okay let's go through ASVs
the last 20 minutes or so of our talk
last ten minutes hey camera guy hey
camera guy what time am I talking to
camera guy sir but the next talk is at
10:00 though right brilliant so let's
let's go through ASVs here let's go
through ASVs let's go through the major
sections of ASV this right we completely
revamped first of all what do I mean by
architecture so at this level we're
talking primarily about look please
anybody here do scuba diving any Tsukuba
divers yes there's a famous saying in
the world of scuba diving I don't about
a thousand dives throughout my life I
love diving
so you say plan the dive what's next
dive the plan what if you don't plan to
dive and die of the plan what's likely
to happen you're gonna die scuba diving
is a dangerous sport
I've watched unfortunately that the
displeasure of watching people pass away
who I was diving with like right before
me so this is a real dangerous sport and
now I now I'm an equestrian and I do
like English jumping and that's also
I've watched a lot of people get hurt
doing that I like do crazy things but so
the point is what we're building
software very often if we make mistakes
from a security point of view people are
gonna get a hurt building health care
systems finance systems public safety
systems you make mistakes there people
could die so we got to take this
seriously the goal of the first section
of AFVs is for us to plan the dive from
a security point of view before we go
through the expensive process of
implementation so we want to make sure
that that teams are using a secure
software development lifecycle where
security is baked into every step of
developing software we're also requiring
threat modeling where you're going over
your initial architecture running
simulated attacks through that system
and identifying any missing defenses or
mitigations that you need to have in
place the goal is not just to build
security in but to design security and
from day one so everyone on the team is
aware of what our security
responsibilities are the second sector
these are like large sections in section
one there's a group of several dozen
requirements I recommend that you go
through again as we move the second
section in AFVs is a section on
authentication this is all about
establishing identity of our users
primarily through a login system and
again we aligned with mist 863 with one
major exception mist 863 was
recommending eight character passwords
which we strongly just we disagree with
fenton on the author so we when we when
we forked 800
63 to ASVs we bumped the minimum
character length of a password to 12
characters we're trying to push the
envelope here a longer password is
always more secure from pure
mathematical point of view what's the
mathematical strength of a password it's
the it's the say remember this it's the
number of characters of the password to
the number of possible characters
powered so yeah so so I have like a 10
character password the strength of that
is 10 to the 80th power approximately
about 80 characters you can pick from
passwords so the longer your password is
and I just got that wrong let me switch
that up it's actually the opposite of
that it's the number of possible
characters in your password 82 the
length of the password power it's
actually 80 to the 10th power bingo
that's their actual strength of a
password so if you increment the length
of a password you're incrementing the
power and he radically increased the
strength of the password the longer it
gets you want to make your password
stronger today take your current
password double it and make that your
new password that will radically
increase the strength of your password
something as simple as that even better
how many of your passwords should you
know today as a user you everyone in the
room how many of your password should
you know why one sir you're right I
think that's a great only have one
password in your mind it should be a
long strong password what password is
that sir bingo that's the right answer
it's the only right answer
the only password we should have in our
mind is one Pat one large password to
manage our password vault where all the
rest of our passwords are 40-plus
characters yes sir what are your three
passwords go ahead
I would have plenty disagree here's why
I shove all my passwords in one password
manager you know why it doesn't matter
because every single system I use uses
multi-factor and when you have
multi-factor in place the loss of your
passwords is much less severity I'll
tell you this if your bank only has
password to login to your bank then I
would agree need a separate password you
need a separate bank a new bank actually
at that point come on this is Europe you
could doing multi-factor at banks for a
long time so if there's no and I've
heard a lot of people say this you use
like tea pass for your work use like a
dashlane or something for your personal
stuff I tend to I use one password
manager with a very long password at a
multi-factor challenge they have all my
passwords in one vault if that vault
gets popped and I went through the
simulation with an attacker friend of
mine then the damage to me would be
almost zero unless they both got my
phone and got my password manager and
that's a very unlikely event so I agree
with you as we go up the maturity
lifecycle have several different
password managers for work or for home
but just use it just for starters use a
password manager it's a good start
and the only password manager that I
would recommend is what you said key
pass that's the only password manager
that's recommended by Tavis normally
from the from the the Google zero day
project projects you've seen the wrong
project Google Georgia corrected me what
like ten times during class right so
project zero this is like this is like
Google basically hired a bunch of bunch
of hit people who are like real gray
attackers these are not like all like
like your perfect noble characters these
are some real iffy characters but some
of the best attackers on the planet and
they gave a hired all these people gave
them ginormous insane unreasonable
salaries and gave them a mission to go
attack any open source software you want
and help make it more secure
this is like yeah I'll give you a big
salary to work wherever you want and go
hack the world's open source it's a
pretty it's a pretty fun job
Tavis is Todd this is one of the world's
best security researchers and attacking
password managers if you ever seen Tavis
or Lee's work by any chance to everyone
anyone anyone here this gentleman
Tavis is on an Internet and the thing is
Tavis is really unhinged he's like he's
got so much ability to crack anything
he's a little busy young man he's a
little bit of unique character he'll do
stuff like this hey one password
it's Friday night 8 o'clock and I'm
dumping a whole bunch of other Billy's
on your team yeah that I just ripped
your password manager to shreds so guess
what that team is doing all weekend yeah
they're looking for fixing bugs so you
thought he's just an interesting
character a lot of people finally be a
controversial character and I agree he
is but you know what else he is he's the
best person in the world who's hacking
password managers of the day and I think
his advice is good and the only password
manager he's not been able to crack open
pretty broadly is key pass and you use
if you use key pass first of all it has
the worst user interface ever written by
a piece of software but it's got some of
the best crypto ever written it's really
solid so key passes a is a recommended
password manager for what it's for it's
worth all right where we were where are
we where are we good didn't you yeah we
brought in password recovery store
requirements for storing credentials
what do you think folks how do you store
a password in a database for a user if
you're building your own crew your own
Authenticator and you want to store a
user's password to verify their password
how do you properly store a password as
part of one of the requirements we have
in ASVs pardon me : Percival says good
job that's one of the only three
acceptable answers using s crypt s crypt
will let you give it a delay factor to
slow down its operation during login and
also give you a memory factor to force
usage of memory on your server
during the comparison with s crypt we
recommend you use a script with at least
16 megabytes of RAM usage shouldn't hurt
scalability that much a work factor
should be approximately a 13 or more and
so I digress what are the other two at
mr. s crypt want to keep playing what
are the other two acceptable algorithms
for password storage that doesn't matter
knowledge is knowledge keep going
B crypt is ver is the most common
acceptable algorithm for password
storage use a work factor of 13 or more
s crypt Colin Percival is the second
best one out there as a memory cost as
well what's the third one you remember
argon 2 which has a memory cost it has a
it has a time factor to slow it down you
can also force only one thread of
operation on that algorithm at any one
time just to minimize attacks against it
from a supercomputing point of view so
these are the only good three required
three password storage algorithms and
the word in the world today we have that
as clear standards and ASVs
we're also pushing a lot of the stronger
multi-factor standards to try to push
people away from SMS and number based
authentication any kind of Authenticator
that text you or has you type in a
number as a second factor is rather poor
we should use cryptographic signing and
and other kinds of strong authentication
that we see in smart cards and yuba keys
and similar and this is what Fido is all
about in section 3 of ASVs
were mostly concerned and the big change
here is the world of standard sessions
of a web application is going away
why do sessions not work in a micro
service architecture micro service is
right you have a hundred different small
services why does traditional session
management not work well for that kind
of architecture anyone number one you
can't really do logging out easily with
the JSON web token
with across many many web services to
log out a stateless mechanism is
challenging there's a bigger reason what
I'll get back to that why does why is
again traditional session management if
you have a fleet of a hundred services
why is that not going to work because in
a micro service environment I'm making a
request that may use multiple serve
multiple micro services or multiple
service functions and how do you track
that the user is logged in to each and
every one of these independent micro
services are you gonna have every one of
your micro services check in a central
location to see if that sessions are
still active is that gonna work
no scalability goes away so when we move
to micro services we need some kind of
artifact that the service can check by
itself in a stateless fashion to see if
that user is logged in and that's what a
JSON web token is all about this is a
radical change and how we build
applications we've added new
requirements to address the use of JSON
web tokens and stateless based
authenticate a stateless based session
management that's become so important in
the world of API design we have several
requirements of access control I keep
trying to push really strong
requirements here I get a little bit
pushback my basic rule of thumb is stop
using roles as a pet in the world of
access control parlance a pet is called
a policy enforcement point it's the
check you do encode for access control
and my vote is we have got to stop hard
coding roles in our code to do access
control
it's a highly flawed anti-pattern from a
security point of view you're a dotnet
community what kind of capability I just
had the word I was going to say what
kind of access control capability does
dot that have from version one that no
other language has done well and I can't
gave the answer capabilities where we're
checking on the name of the feature
encode not the role of a user you should
be hard coding in your code the feature
name and use and use groups and similar
in your back-end database if
you're the reason we need to get away
from roles is because of things like
multi tenants if I have multiple
companies using my app and they all want
different access control policy roles
breakdown what about the simple as
simple as a data check for example think
of this message system API something or
other comm / messages / 1 2 3 4 suppose
that's the message I'm reading how can i
hack that URL to look at other people's
messages change a number how long would
it take you to write a script to try
every single number against that API sir
yeah 5 minutes right are you a full time
employee sir yeah if you're a full time
employee
writing this script to try every number
against an API image take you 5 minutes
now if you're a contractor like me
that's at least a two-week project
that's a different story that's a I know
you heard that stupid joke before
several times sorry Robin alright so
jokes aside go to any web app go to any
API start fiddling with the numbers and
if you could start seeing data that
other users should only be able to look
at guess what you just found an act a
major data contain eccentric access
control problem and so and but and the
point I'm trying to make is when you
hard code rolls it doesn't address these
data issues at all so I I digress that's
the heart of the access control section
to move us towards more modern access
control like capabilities and an
attribute based enforcement points a
good hygiene in software is to do input
validation and so we talked about some
of the more modern needs here to address
things like deserialization attacks we
want to validate the objects that were
allowed to serialize to we want to stop
server side request forgery which
involves us validating open redirects
and the safe construction of URLs in
inside of your API architecture we want
to do output output encoding to stop
cross-site scripting we want to do HTML
sanitization also and all these
techniques of data handling are set as
requirements in this in this section of
the standard store cryptography the big
in the stored cryptography section is
where you store a key where is a good
place to store a key in an application a
cryptographic key that's verifying a
signature or encrypting credit cards are
similar where's a good place to store a
key somebody say the registry caught
just someone say the registry go on say
it
that's a horrible answer what's wrong
with you I'm sorry we should be putting
keys in some kind of hardware security
module or some kind of key management
service or a secret vault and things
like your your production password
what's where it's not a good place to
check in your production password to
your corporate database github that's
right now the best place to store your
you know your production password so we
want to use these modern secret vaults
to store our application class secrets
so if you are hacked those critical
secrets and keys have less chance of
being stolen
err get two errors let's move on v8 data
protection now we're talking about
things like HTTPS be careful of using
html5 local storage for sensitive data
and of course we're adding a lot of
requirements about gdpr and other
privacy laws we have in the u.s.
california privacy law is very similar
to gdpr a quick note on privacy and data
protection why is your grocery bill the
food that you go shopping for of the
highest level of privacy data according
to GDP our GDP our has like three
classes of data the top two are private
user data and extremely private user
data which requires extra controls and
explanation for why you're using them
why is your grocery bill the highest
level of severity in terms of secret
data a private data in the world GDP our
what what can I do from your crow siree
bill that's just private about you two
major things what's that I can figure
out medical issues I can also figure out
often your religion as well these are
and these are very private things
especially especially in Europe right so
we've added some of those requirements
in to bring gdpr into the standard as
well and they note gdpr is not just a
European thing the u.s. is quickly
rolling in that direction as well
California's privacy law is so strong
anyone who wants to do business in the
US like for example if I go back ten
years and I wanted to write software for
Europe Europe had gdpr
and print every country had their own
version of it and when Germany had the
strongest rules in this area and so if I
basically wrote application to satisfy
Germany's privacy laws then I was good
through the rest of Europe for the most
part and so that now u.s. is going
through that same life cycle a couple
years behind Europe if you write code
and satisfy California's privacy law
then you're good for the whole US it's
the strongest law we have right now so
these privacy issues they're important
across the whole world it's becoming
such an issue that Facebook just sent a
big warning out there Facebook is
crushing it making money because you all
use Facebook even though you know it's
probably not the most private software
in the world to use
but Facebook gave us a warning yesterday
that said the era of privacy is getting
so strong it's gonna get it's gonna be
much more difficult for us to make money
on advertisements in the future and even
though our user base is going up
dramatically the amount of money we can
make per user from advertisements is
going down so the game of war and their
stock dropped heavily last night because
of this warnings too I thought was kind
of interesting the nine communication
security how often should you be using
well-configured
HTTPS in your work how often should you
be using HTTPS and your work as a
developer is there ever a good excuse to
use HTTP in your work keep calm and use
HTTPS sir right is there ever a good
excuse to use HTTP anyone who wants to
play no I'm sorry yes no do you reckon
stuff sir
what was your comment
inside the data center is the absolute
worst place to do some use HTTP and let
me explain why sir a lot of
organizations in their data center
they'll stick all their private entrant
in epi is in their data center right in
a private network just for their
intranet api's and by the way your
intranet api's what kind of data do they
sling around probably some of the most
sensitive data and features of your
whole company and what folks do is they
go I'm gonna build this private network
just for my internal api's and I'll only
allow my production apps
talk to those api's and now I have this
private network in in a private network
in my data center where all my internet
API czar with no HTTP weak
authentication or no authentication no
access control I'm sorry but inside the
inside the actual API network itself
it's all HTTP you're saying that's a
common thing but and you'll connect to
that network through HTTP it'll
terminate but everything's plain text in
that API network guess what hackers do
for a living they get into your private
networks that's what they did that's
what they do
so hacker if I'm a hacker and I get into
your private API network what do I get
my hands on everything it's game effing
over for your whole company at that
point and so the older philosophy on
security was let's build a hard shell
around our infrastructure and have a
soft Center cuz no hacker would ever get
there well 10 years later guess what
hackers get there this has led to the
largest healthcare breach of all time
this has led to the largest financial
breach of all time and similar the new
philosophy of modern security is let's
go look at Google standards for a second
I got four minutes I'll use it Google
Google and now Google is not a perfect
company I don't like what they do for a
living around privacy but
like the engineers that work for them
that drive web security my quest might
Samuel we shall spend you alone Lucas
why Siobhan these are leaders and
application security that published
public standards to the world and what
there are rules of play r4 api's
whenever you deploy an API in public or
in private the standard is the same
strong HTTP strong authentication at
every API level no free lunch and strong
access control at every API so every
individual Michael service should force
me to be logged in should know who I am
no my access control rules before it
lets me run a feature that's what we
need for modern day security this and
I'm not picking on you this is a common
architectural mistake where we have this
hard outside world and this insecure
soft center hackers will get there and
when they do get there it's game over
so please please be careful of that so
let me go back to you Rick how often
should we use HTTPS how often should our
services do strong authentication always
how often should our API is too strong
access control always it's easy again my
job is to like read white papers and do
powerpoints and preach hey it's my job
I've now told you what to do my job is
done and now get to work for thousands
of hours to pull that off good luck with
that I know it's not easy to take a
legacy system and that your debt has a
certain way of going certain way of
running and bring it up to these modern
standards it's what we got to do I'm
gonna skip malicious code business logic
verification the whole point here is
these are vulnerabilities that scanners
will not find this is the custom
business logic flaws something as simple
as an e-commerce checklist where I skip
the payment step no scanner in the world
will find that Allah and v12 is file
security things like server side request
forgery again and like and remote file
included and similar attacks against
like PHP type architectures and of
course a whole new section on rest
security of a whole new section on graph
QL and other modern API standards
including including more requirements on
jots orge
policy is a big deal in the modern API
era and similar and we have to get on
and now security is frequently driven by
configuration now that you know about a
SBS you know I want you to consider
these requirements for every single
security task that we need to do during
the sdlc and how do you use it I
recommend you fork it you want to paint
a picture of this go ahead go for it
real quick I got rid all right let's do
let's do this let me act smart go go go
quick
Thanks thank you fingers real quick
almost almost done and so how do you use
it for kit work with your developers and
security team and forth this standard
custom to your organization it's all
it's a public standard last release was
March of 2019 grab it off of github
thank you so much for your time you can
contact me either for the oauth
Foundation or for my private job
actually I wouldn't use an email address
that's a sequel injection payload let's
use that one instead it's my great
pleasure to be here at NDC
go forth and write secure code if you
have questions I'll hang out after here
go forth and write secure code thank you
very much for being here everybody
I'll take one question real quick
anybody have any questions no questions
yes sir
it's a question is is there anything in
ASVs about webassembly
so you think it's a straight you want to
like take like native c-sharp code and
run it like assembly in the browser is
that what you're saying yeah I do not
believe we requirement to such a
brand-new architecture I know it's real
popular in the.net world we try to keep
away from singular language things it's
not in there yet it's something we
should address in the next and the next
version of ASVs
so I have a mission for you are you
ready sir go to a SDS github go to the
4.0 branch and add an issue for us to
remind us to add to add web assembly
requirement to the next version will you
take that on for me just go to github
ASVs and add a comment and I'll address
it personally I have a great day thank
you so much everybody all right
[Applause]